israel is really heating up now after
brussels made that threat that it will
look to ban
exports of the kovid 19 vaccine from the
block
that's going to have massive
implications not just for the uk but
also other countries in the world and
this comes amidst a huge shortage
of the kovid 19 vaccine here in the eu
now leaders are meeting on friday to
discuss whether
national regulators are going to get
these powers to say
no you cannot export any of the vaccine
that is produced within the european
union and first that could be hit hard
is the uk which currently is waiting on
a shipment
of some 40 million doses of the fisa
biontech vaccine
that's produced in belgium of course if
that export ban comes in
it won't be getting those doses while
continuing dialogue i believe the eu
needs to take robust action to secure
its supply of vaccines
and demonstrate concretely that the
protection of its citizens remains our
absolute priority
well this of course comes amidst a huge
spat over the last days
between the eu and also the
anglo-swedish pharmaceutical group
this is astrazeneca now astrazeneca
which has plants in the uk
and in belgium had made this order this
commitment with the eu
last year when it was researching the
vaccine it's now turned around to the eu
and said we're only going to be able to
supply
25 of the doses uh that we said we would
by the
end of march and this is a massive
problem for the eu
because it's not just being dealt this
bloom now by astrazeneca which says it's
got production problems
but it's also been told similar things
by fisa biontech that it simply cannot
produce
the number of vaccines that it said it
would be able to do
now the shortages are already impacting
many areas of europe for example here in
france
paris and other regions in the country
have said that they're going to have to
delay the rollout
of their vaccine program while in spain
in the capital in madrid it's already
said it's having to halt its program
and has warned that that could also be
the case
in catalonia so really not good news as
this comes amidst huge criticism
of how the eu has rolled out this
program of vaccination
trying to get to all countries at the
same time and obviously finding itself
relatively in short supply but
the eu is pointing the blame firmly
at that anglo-swedish firm astrazeneca
will suffer if they treat people in the
world's biggest market as second-class
citizens
to add to all of this investigators have
now been sent to the astrazeneca plant
in belgium
to check that they were in fact telling
the truth that there was
a problem with production then that's
because there's a suggestion that
millions of doses had already been
sent to the uk and that has left the eu
furious because it says it's invested a
huge amount of money in astrazeneca
money astro zenica says it hasn't
received much of
for the moment but it does seem that the
eu is now moving towards
a europe-first strategy a strategy that
it's oft criticized
when it's been deployed by other
countries